for first we feast I'm Sean Evans and
this is hot ones the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Anthony Rizzo blood
call the face of the 2015 Chicago Cubs
how's it going man it's going great how
are you we have 10 questions to ask you
we have 10 wings for you to eat and what
we do is we start off easy
then we creep our way up the Scoville
scale to the end with a wing that'll
just blow your cleats off probably if
you can make it through 10 wings you get
30 seconds of uninterrupted time to plug
whatever you want if you can't handle
the heat there's a safe word you say rod
Beck and it's over but I'm gonna take 15
seconds of your 30-second plug and you
don't want that to happen because I'm in
a while out that's how I'm good
yeah all right mr. Rizzo are you ready
for your hot ones let's do this
so we're starting out the Texas Pete hot
sauce nothing right no not something
you're in trouble ma'am I know during
spring training
Will Ferrell you took over your position
at first base coach some third for the
Cubs and I have to think that you or
someone on the roster has to have a
little ferrule story for sharing the
diamond with him that day you know what
I wasn't there that day all right number
two we got the Tabasco green sauce gonna
do dude what's the most savage ruthless
thing the st. Louis Cardinals fans ever
yelled at you
they just when I saw so this one is
about 77% the heat of a jalapeno so
we're starting to like kind of approach
a real pepper territory okay all right
pasta graph definitively which side is
more lit rowdier more intense the left
field bleachers of the right field
bleachers
it's left field bleachers now this one
is just a pure Cayenne just an uncut
cayenne pepper a bit wet it's 3:00 in
the morning you're calling it a night in
Wrigley bill do you go to that Taco Bell
on Addison or do you take your chances
with that McDonald's on Clark it just
depends on the mood just to be honest
either-or but I'm a big Taco Bell fan
we got a Caribbean habanero
this one has a fruity flavor but no joke
like it'll kick little bit you have a
safe word I have never come across a
wing in my life that I couldn't handle
and I want everyone out there to know
that you're a ball player you're a
rapper you're a celebrity you want to
come in here the hot ones and you think
that you're gonna beat me is never ever
gonna have I'm just wondering your safe
word well I just let you know I don't
let me ask you this I know you're
Italian through it through but I think
that you spent enough time in Chicago to
have tried Gino's East to have tried Lou
Malnati's deep-dish pizza
is it really Pizza it is pizza
yes you ready to go to six still
louisiana-style yeah straight up the
bayou something that you put on crawfish
it's a habanero jalapeno sort of mix
good produce you're hot in the heat of
battle tempers can flare but I wonder in
baseball when is that line crossed when
does it go from trash talk to say
flipping your helmet flipping your glove
and just beasting up to the entire Reds
dugout um it just depends on the
situation honestly uh fighting is never
the cure to anything but you gotta stick
up your teammates I'm with that 100% how
are you feeling I'm feeling alive this
one has pain right in the title
this is two and a half times as hot as a
jalapeno what do I do it in the
distinguished history of famous people
with bleached blond hair look I want to
know how does your spring training look
stack up to Justin Timberlake Oh
Eminem Justin Bieber and Guy Fieri
mighty Rock super vests then you got to
go Slim Shady
Oh Guy Fieri I would go down the Biebs
and that might is the worst for sure
this is a bad look
that's humble I think you might have
shortchanged Fieri a little bit but
other than that have no problem I can't
even hear what you're saying so I
balanced on a fire you can always call
him the save
cuz there's three and I'll tell you
about this last one not to psych you out
or anything but the Mad Dog 357 is 71
point four times a jalapeno that one
that you said smelled smoky I'm gonna
drink your milk here in a second yeah
both do we have more milk number eight
we're going to something that's six
times hotter than a jalapeno they
actually call this one Blair's
original death sauce sweet
who in the Cubs clubhouse gets pranked
the most who gets the hotfoot who gets
the shaving cream pie
who gets the bubblegum bubble on top of
their calf lows often did the day I
probably [ __ ] myself you catch it the
most it's odd to me cuz you're like what
like 240
Dave's insanity hot sauce thirty-six
times a jalapeno
all right cheers Cheers man that one
that was a good one Dave golly I'm good
I love it I love it baseball players the
notoriously superstitious hitters
especially story that sticks out to me
to keep it cubs moist I salute peeing on
his hands to toughen them up and I'm
wondering do you have any bizarre
strange rituals when it comes to your
game
um morning routine got to get up and get
my shaving in and feeling good Nivea men
hug that after I eat this last one here
but uh I catch myself being a little
superstitious just like if you do
something the day before you just do it
again they get if you got a hit or home
or whatever to get a homer yesterday and
then you ate wings you had a homer
tomorrow I'll be back you're eating
wings got it
you're the first person and make it to
number 10
seriously yeah how many times you've
done this just one other time but use
your body your body tony yayo fuji unit
nice no way oh Christ next level right
beer bro this is the mad dog 357 hot
sauce pure chili abstract and fresh
habaneros seventy one point four times
hotter than a jalapeno
good thing I've had this one before you
had it before I told you I like wind
you're no joke ma'am last question as
you look back on this interview do you
think this is possibly the worst
decision of your career you know what I
didn't make this decision this but
whoever it is it's probably the worst
decision of theirs amazing man you may
hate hell yeah giving Rizzo all man
and he gets 30 uninterrupted seconds to
talk about whatever he wants
I can't even chime in and I had a whole
stunt planned and everything you could
do it afterwards I can handle it you got
one
all right fine we'll see about that go
ahead take your 30 seconds all right for
as yours partnered up with Nivea men to
get a clean start to the day and I'm a
big believer in that with the
superstitions in baseball she's all
about confidence and that's but I feel
like life is all about a few you're
confident with something and you believe
you fit in then you're gonna be there
with Nivea man they give you a fresh
start and a clean star that you need
it's been great so far we're gonna all
right well what's your dad's name
John John first shout out John because
you just raised a wing eating maniac so
I do want to start my plug by shouting
out Anthony Rizzo who but oh gosh what I
would like to say big up my Chicago
White Sox shout-out Jose Abreu the best
first baseman in Chicago thank you man
I'm just playing with you appreciate it
you see it